you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens hey guys welcome back to
the show you're watching tomorrow daily
which is AC net show we hijacked the
gamespot co-op stage here at e3 2016
you'll never know will never find it
here I'm Ashley sceva hello and my
wonderful co-host Jeff kanata's hanging
out with me here on stage and we have a
very special guest it's my old boss
hello my friend Nick Lucas is here we
have what like three shows combined on
yeah actually with all of yours that's
like six shows right come on shout out
here oh my going on and he shows you
have EPN TV TV yes and your host and
creator yep so for you III means what uh
well you know what I bet this is I've
been all of them this is Monsieur 22nd
III 22nd he threw out and early on when
we were in sort of creating demos and
pilots for electric playground in the
very beginning of 95 this was mecca back
then I knew that this was going to be
the most important event for the video
game industry it was in Atlanta then
right yeah the very first one oh no the
first one was in LA we did two years in
LA and that two years in atlanta i came
back to LA but so this has always been
mecca this has always been like a very
just important i was going to say
spiritual but it's not spiritual it's
just an incredibly important trip for
the entire community to come and get
together and see all of this stuff and
celebrate this business and I feel it's
incredibly important to continue to do
that because the games industry needs to
kind of show that this is a valuable art
form on a consistent basis and of course
that's been my whole career on
television is to kind of put cameras in
people's faces and really show off this
art form convince people that this is
high art just as you would say cinema is
my thing Lou I think this year is a
great testament to that we've seen some
really amazing games obviously people
lost their minds when we saw God war
come back
it looks very cinematic we were talking
about that earlier job yeah I mean I
think they took a franchise that let's
be honest was pretty juvenile yeah and
they actually managed to make it ground
it and substantial and have this nuance
story that's really about parenting and
being an adult well I think just the way
that Grand Theft Auto kind of
transitioned us into a more mature kind
of art you know look at this art form
and the idiom and ways to tell stories I
think the same can be said for the last
of us yeah and I feel like the effects
of the last of us we're gonna continue
to feel but I have to say something
about that sony press conference I've
seen every press conference so that Sony
one was a very special one and I think
it was kind of reflected in a little bit
of the Sean Laden remarks about the
awful stuff that happened in rural land
over at the beginning sure but there was
a maturity and a confidence in the
stories that were told just in those
little visual snippets that I think were
profound and the to think that people in
theaters all over America and I think
some in candidates who were able to
watch that as a show was very important
and I feel that the business can learn a
lot from that kind of presentation break
games it was a very mature presentation
and like you said I think confidence was
such a big part of that presentations
they said we don't need to bring anybody
out we don't need to do demos we're not
going to even talk about it like no even
when kijima came out it was just like
here's what I've been working on hope
you love it like and everybody was just
like I don't know what crazy thing this
is yeah but Norman Reedus and the baby
of a craziness and they have been but we
love it we want to plan just just to
have that much time on Rita's face while
he's holding the baby and he's crying
that was significant very poignant yeah
yeah in a been do we use the word and
the word that they used on stage was
show yeah and I think it wasn't a press
conference that they realized that this
isn't a press conference it really is a
show they approached it like a
theatrical event though having the live
music there and being on that beautiful
shrine auditorium stage with the dual
LEDs already was unbelievable yeah I
mean I think I think you're going to see
moving forward it becoming even more
presentation rather than a press as it
should be you know like I just interview
sam witwer who's the star of days gone
and he's a face that gamers know from
other games and we should kind of put
these pieces together you know it was
just announced before the before e3 that
Jon Snow is the it is going to live ill
in and call of duty and you know not to
say that we need to put celebrities in
all of this but there needs to be this
kind of entertainment familiarity with
these properties and right and the
people behind them you need a little bit
of that with with Nolan Norris and we I
mean you see a little bit of that but it
hasn't reached quite the fever pitch I
think that we see obviously in movies
yes television well and the other thing
I'd like to see is more and what you
guys are doing here and you know I think
it's amazing I've never had a stage at
e3 I've always you know hustled my butt
from one native wait for the next yes
but I i think that to like put this the
developers in the middle of a stage like
this and to turn the cameras on them and
make that a show as well as very
important that I quad gamespot for doing
that that's awesome yeah and and you
know it's just a couple of years ago
that the press conference was getting on
stage and showing flow charts and graphs
graphs and say we've sold X number of
consoles and it's it really happened
very quickly yeah you know I've been
fortunate enough to be in this business
for a long time and I've seen that
evolution from it being a tech and
product based industry to a full-fledged
we understand this is an entertainment
industry and I need to when you think
it's entertainment industry yeah it's
past box office almost regularly now for
how many years like few years it has but
there's a bit of a misconception around
that because of the price on games I
think that it has an effective as many
lives yeah as movies and television like
not as many people individuals consume
this stuff on a regular basis and know
all the intricacies of this stuff and
that's what I've endeavoured to do with
with my programming and what gamespot is
endeavor to do and you're and who said
you're hustling your butt around here
yeah so what have you seen on the show
floor yeah just in the first couple of
days that has impressed you most well I
I'm a huge sci-fi nerd I love that and I
love that call of duty went in that
direction a few years ago but now
androids seemed to be in Deus Ex robots
and Detroit and we've got
call of duty robot I'm so looking at all
right and fall to his height and so
amazing oh it's a big shooter year yeah
sure I talked about that yesterday that
the resurgence of FPS games this is like
a very big shooter year and and yeah a
lot of older franchises coming back a
lot of newer franchises Mannering the
mix yep pretty great but the fact that
Nintendo has one game to play yeah I
think speaks volumes to the quality of
that game as you say and what a game it
is we all thought we all thought they
were insane and then you walk into that
booth and you're like oh no they created
a magical fantasy we're almost a whole
lucky I oh yeah and you don't want to
leave you know right and nothing can
sort of shake it from your mind right
you want a total shameless
self-promotion but if anybody wants to
we have a 360 video of the on cnet's
YouTube page we have a 360 video it's
real short and you can look around
inside the Nintendo boutique also and
it's worth looking into I mean there's
it's so cacophonous here yeah then you
walk into that Nintendo booth initialism
know you're in a hyrule yeah yeah that's
the game too right i mean there are
there is a lot of killing and death like
there always is at e3 and then you go
into zelda and it's like you know what
I'm saying it's like Miyazaki meets
Miyamoto kind of a kind of vibe and it's
uh it's you know regardless of whatever
your feelings are on Nintendo this is
something that every buddy that likes
this medium needs to cease fire they
should aspire to write up and it I love
how they're willing to take a risk with
such a storied franchise and it really
does feel like okay we're put all in on
this and it's a little crazy like it's
not like any zelda you've played before
yep but we think it works and we're
really excited about it and we hope that
you'll buy it alongside our new console
Middle's ourselves like remember those
like 80 hours you put into the last Elda
that's a drop in the bucket as to what
you might be having a put into this one
and I think that that speaks to the you
know the the relevance and the maturity
of the Western RPGs sure I mean Final
Fantasy 15 is a reflection of that as
well yeah the you know Bioware's and
Bethesda's of the world have just been
making things that have you know shocked
the business from a very you know
staunch old guard the JRPG scene was the
way that we played our people waited
nothing really
lifted and now we have an open world
kitchen sink experience with Final
Fantasy 15 and an open world Zelda for
the first time yeah very very amazing
amazing and the thing about the Zelda
thing to that I always find really
remarkable too is I don't believe that
it's the top-selling of the Nintendo
franchises it always does well but
clearly it is always the most expensive
to make yeah of the Nintendo franchises
and I applaud Nintendo for doing that
because they don't have to yeah but they
do do that and don't come from a
personal compromise yeah prestige brand
of Nintendo it's like the prestige
franchise your heel it when you play
that game I play there's a thousand open
world games on the show floor yeah play
that one and you go there's a level of
Polish that's immediately palpable
totally yeah yeah oh I'm asking
everybody about VR yeah yes what's your
talking about VR it's big presence here
I you know I have to confess I have not
really sunk in on the trade show floor
okay and it's mostly to do with my
vanity and I can't believe I'm revealing
you know what hey your hair I don't want
yeah you don't want someone were your
face picture it is yes you don't want
someone to go by with you like hey and
so I actually told and you know and now
it's out thankfully like it's actually
available I know your captain VR I love
it you've been talking at you have a VR
super suit underneath that do indeed I
just rip it off at certain points we
hadn't try on on our show at Tesla sooo
that works with VR where he'd say
actually shocked it electrically really
when you get yeah sorry yeah well
actually I told oculus and be ours like
I want to come for your demos but we've
done so many demos stories yeah and
they're all of them art well this is
amazing this is amazing and I said look
we just gotta start reviewing this stuff
and that and that will be our coverage
because I feel like consumers really
want to know yeah you know and they're
hearing it from you they're like bye-bye
but it I love it all right which is
great but I feel like consumers really
want the scoop is this stuff worth the
investment is it worth the time and what
games are really worth playing so I'm
excited to be at home in my underwear
playing my VR and then conveying how I
feel about
so inter I'm curious about this because
right now in VR we're seeing a lot of
experiences yeah full games resident
evil will be I think one of the bigger
full games that will see in the next
year so next year fallout I mean I'm
really excited about those but a lot of
the stuff like like Batman alright
Arkham vrs is it's an experience and
it's it's an amazing experience yeah but
it's an experience yeah and do you think
that that is the thing that gamers
should be excited about or should they
and maybe get into VR to try those
things out and get experimental with it
so that like Jeff they're sort of really
familiarized with VR or is it something
that it's like well maybe you should
wait and then when you come into it
later when full games start coming out
in in force yeah then you'll be able to
sort of check out those others I think
this is an eternal challenge in this
game industry right I think that we need
to have those tests amount kind of
experiences like on the wii but we also
need to see that there is a product that
is you cannot miss right right and I
think that oculus and vive as much as I
have seen them haven't really got that
everybody needs this experience you know
they need that story the storied console
seller right yeah you know you can
define it down to roil it down to killer
app but I feel like like the Scorpio now
for Xbox one has a little bit of that
same issue right now they talked about
something that I think every fan of nur
a video game you know culture wants but
we don't know why we want it yet yeah it
comes down to boiling it down to we just
hear teraflops thick and we just go
crazy yeah well we reply I went crazy
for that I know I still don't know why
yeah yeah I gotta see why I think the BR
is in that same dilemma I think the we
was in that dilemma I think the d/s was
in that dilemma then the 3ds was in that
villa in the will you isn't it and a wii
u i think it's a cyclical thing it's one
of the big challenges of a tech based
entertainment thing but salsa mix the
business so fun and exciting and care
scary and weird and you know just a
perpetual thrill to cover you know well
it's been awesome having you on man
I really appreciate it tell people where
you can find your stuff EPN TV we're
we're we're posting all kinds of stuff
and of course like everybody else we're
testing a lot of content on Facebook
right now on our Facebook page awesome
then uh at Victor underscore Lucas
throughout the race for Lucas yep very
well thank you so much for stopping by
everybody give Vic nice round of
applause we thank you we are gonna be
back well we're done here for the week
but Jeff you've got a lot of other stuff
going on yeah we're gonna be coming TF
from this stage for more III coverage to
stick around he doesn't even know what
show is on no idea I'm not leaving this
stage he lives here now we'll know until
everyone talks about VR tomorrow daily
we'll be back next week at its regular
time in place at our Burbank studio and
you can go to tomorrow daily com you
want to see more of our show it's about
future check pop culture video games we
love it and and until then vegan humans
will see you guys bye awesome